[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais amoureux de Lucy qui vivait dans
le SUS j'abitais Sucy dans l'abri ça me
donnait des complexes alors j'ai pris le
férie moi qui suis mal enur mais pour
mal luie ma chérie rien n'est assez cher
j'arrivais là-bas plein d'espoir mais
j'ai eu les grosot quand j'ai découvert
que la gare s'appelait
waterlo ils ont des chapau melon vivent
la GrandeBretagne ils boivent du des
citron vivent les grands bretons et
chant vive la reine et chant vive les
béc malgré
Napoléon vivent les grands bretons Lucy
m'attendait sur le qu dans sa petite
robe à fleur son père en tenue de
criquet et sa mère en pleur je savais
my il m'ont dit il on est arrivé au cott
au m du depuis la grandmère jusqu' c
tout
étap il ont des ch grand
[Musique]
ilré
napolé quand j'ai déclaré tout est
m'a gentiment
répondu alors je lui ai fait des bisous
[Musique]
des chezous tout compris maintenant je
suis
[Musique]
muB
jeis la grande bretag
ilit viv les grand chant on vive la
reine et chantons vive les U PLC malgré
Napoléon vive les grands
Bredon